is a sad video I don't know
I see people embracing tears in their
eyes must be sad the definition of said
well hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm Ashley editor yes you know I'm
just sick of introducing Ashley is one
of my children from donating sperm
transition a sperm donor meets his 19
children all together I can't really was
a little bit why Gary you're going for I
once had a Bourne movie idea that was
similar to this so Bourne movie Bourne
Identity yeah it's got the Bourne family
tree where he the woman he's been with
and then like 19 children show up at his
door a little bit of both depending on
the perspective of the audience right so
he has to figure out who did he sleep
with let's do this it's a magical moment
at an airport as the father greets a
daughter he has never met this is my
daughter number 19 that's right Michael
Rubino has 19 actual name whoa they're
like all good looking for like an
appropriate outsider perspective
[Laughter]
they range in age from 16 to 21
kinda sounds like a TV sitcom only this
family story has a huge twist he wasn't
there no I knew when I was a donor I
sort of expected I might if I'm very
lucky me two or three in his 30s Michael
an artist decided to become a donor to
help others start families remain
anonymous not my tip I wanted to put in
my file there a letter saying you know
just so that we're clear on this if any
turn up at any time I'm available so I
was looking forward to it
as soon as I wrote him a letter he wrote
me one back like instantly before
Michael knew it more and more kids
started contacting him for all of you
sitting here well I think that you're
sitting next to your brother or a sister
how does that feel anyway some things
they're also sweet and just fine to get
to know the siblings zero in on their
similarities and I could just tell we're
all like kind of bubbly just had the
same energy
she's the love seeing their
[Music]
discover they share his passion for
animals and artists Wow some of the kids
like yeah
calling someone who didn't raise me dad
felt weird when I have a dad he's like
very much in my life I consider him my
dad because he's the only dad I know but
[Music]
that's as adorable I don't know why my
mind just jumps all the worst possible
conclusions what are your thoughts and
I'll share mine well I have a few
questions I have all the answers
thank God so they're all different
mothers they must be uh-huh
so like this guy gives his swimmers all
these children are just like from
different moms all over the world yeah I
don't know about the world but wherever
he was living I forgot where they said
where they said that he did it because
he wanted to help people start families
I thought people donate sperm when
they're like struggling with money well
I know when friends that's why Joey did
it so yeah it must be
that's the cliche is that like you're a
dude and you qualify better paying gig
than do donate sperm and get paid I said
I would never do it because I don't want
to be in that situation
he seems like kids yeah he seems like
such a proud father for not having
raised any of it he can do which is he
he opted Tuesday that he's available to
them I think like I just think you were
to do it you could put like don't
contact me ever I would put down John's
name this is your
but like so you could you could do it
that way so he must be happy to have all
these kids and that's really cute that
the one daughter like she doesn't have a
dad really cuz obviously something
happened there so now like that's the
new daddy why'd that mom accept this
from if there wasn't going to be a male
figure and the person's life because she
could do it on her own you don't need a
man listen I'm all it's better to raise
a child in the house as well this is so
funny seeing this guy be so proud and
I'm like thank you my accomplishments of
all these children that I did not
personally have any involvement that is
interesting I wonder if any of them have
tried to get a hold of him before now
like why now all of a sudden all of them
you know what I mean have they trinkle
din slowly or has it just been one big
like foot 19 I think I think I think
they have been like bit like the trinkle
message I think it was that because he
had photos of them when they were like
really young inside of his house in
there and there somebody like you need
updated photos of us so maybe they've
been around for a long time that's cool
some of them are like artist and
somebody cuz he was yeah there's this
one shot I mean there's plenty of this
one shot let me screenshot it for my own
record you like the one in the blue
dress I don't want to say cuz I don't
know how old any of it
you see they all said 1621 I'm like well
I don't know who sixteen and I don't
know he's 21
let's just watch my mouth cuz when I was
looking at this that's I think that's
when I said like oh she's the prettiest
one because I would think as like if all
these siblings who don't know each other
I might be a little insecure and be like
men
what if I show up in that room and I'm
like all 18 of my siblings are
better-looking than me so I wanted to
see like who's the least attractive one
out of all these people looks because it
looks or everything everything well
maybe they're the most talented one who
have like a fascinating story I just I
would hate I would not feel he's
probably older but he looks great for
his age because he didn't have the
stress of raising the kids
yeah why are they there yeah maybe he
doesn't I feel like they would have
showed those kids if he had actual
children here a baby but this is all the
sperm kids you know what I mean I mean
every you know the other ones he wanted
you know say or maybe not I don't know
oh we're musta be to be a kid and just
associate your dad as the person who
gave his sperm yeah like that's like
what comes to mind yes that's what comes
to mind is you just gave you're like
yeah I don't think about my parents and
when they made relations with each other
because they don't say it like that
right
but when you meet the dad you're like oh
you just don't donate it in a cup Here I
am some lived his life saddle a
questioning tale
good thing is they gotta meet their dad
that's now they have all these brothers
and sisters but my question is like now
like do they have all these Christmas
gifts they gotta gimme like problems
right you know especially be weird
there's 19 of them it's like a little
class like what if some of them start
crushing on each other like actually
liking each other yeah well the thing
with siblings I learned this week
documentary is that you have the same
pheromones and so usually you are like
you're the biggest attraction to
somebody else is their pheromones but if
you are related to somebody they have
the same pheromones as you so it cancels
each other on you're not gonna be as
attracted to them well science for you
guys for the day that's true that's a
fact and why does incest happening well
I'm sure there are some cases obviously
that that's what they say how how do my
pheromones know well guys are you a
child of sperm donation do you want to
donate your sperm mail it in to the real
rejects p.o box today we'll take that
off your hands subscribe to the rejects
thanks for sending this video click that
notification bell Ashleigh ender is on
Instagram as Ashley Edgar yes and she
has a YouTube channel how to's with
Morgan and Ashley that's right we show
you how to do stuff yeah channel is
we're a moving review channel we go
review movies for yeah in case that
wasn't made clear we have a patreon
where you can donate your sperm to it
okay and that's all that's required to
get access to it